what's going on everybody it's warren
and welcome back to the cosmic wonder
why we talk all things marvel and mcu
and we have some really really cool new
spider-man no way home footage to go
over today and since yesterday i did my
hawkeye episode 4 breakdown and the day
before that i did the modoc and shangchi
2 news we have a lot to talk about today
in regards to spiderman no way home new
footage and dialogue for the green
goblin in no way home and new footage
and dialogue for doc ock and i'll show
the tv spots and new footage right
before we start talking about them so
it's fresh in your mind and we'll break
it down and today it is officially one
week before the release of spider-man no
way home in theaters one week to go
we're almost there so today in this
video we're going to talk about a big
plot detail that was revealed by alfred
molina who of course plays dot gok in a
recent snippet that was released by sony
then we're going to be talking about the
green goblin the new footage we got
there and a little bit about some new
dialogue that we got from electro and of
course if you love marvel don't forget
to subscribe now we'll start off by
talking about doc and electro but first
let me thank our sponsors for this video
gamer advantage but first big thank you
to gamer advantage for sponsoring this
video if you are a gamer if you play
games on any type of screen if you work
on a computer and you simply want to
sleep better gamer advantage glasses are
for you gamer advantage glasses are more
than just gamer glasses and i'll explain
exactly why this is the only clinically
proven and doctor recommended pair of
glasses of its kind it protects your
eyes and health 24 7. not only do they
keep me from getting headaches or eye
strains after long days in front of the
screen but they also help me sleep
through the night so i can wake up the
next morning energized and ready to do
it all over again and these are actually
incredibly lightweight and they're
flexible so when you put them on they
won't push up your headset they're also
extremely fashionable and they don't
have a yellow tint to them so you can
wear them anywhere and get this they
actually have a magnetic
attachable piece so they turn into
sunglasses and they also have developed
a new gaming snack well technically it's
an eye health supplement but like the
name says eye candy is a delicious
little fruit snack with tons of vitamins
in it that your eyes need for a long
lasting legibility and the best part is
it's ten percent off the entire site
right now and you can stack my discount
on top of it for 20 off the entire site
so click the link in the description
down below to get this deal it lasts
till the end of the year
we got another chance to stir some
things up
how you like the new new electro is like
the world did me wrong now i got this
energy i'm about to go get mine you're
not gonna take this away from me
darkhawk picks up where he left off what
have you done with my machine he's
looking for revenge you want to play
games
the goblin believes in a world of losers
and winners power is all that matters
[Music]
so as we just saw right there the
villains and the actors that are playing
the villains have kind of told us now
what the whole motives are of the
villains in no way home there's not much
new footage on jimmy fox's electro but
we do have some new dialogue from him he
says how do you like the new new and
this is great because they're actually
acknowledging that he looks different
right he's not blue anymore which i like
that they're actually acknowledging this
he is actually changed they're not going
to act like he was this way the entire
time they're acknowledging the change
they've confirmed he has an arc reactor
so he's clearly channeling all of this
energy that he has inside of him and
jamie foxx actually goes on to say the
world did him wrong and now he's got
this energy and he's about to go get his
so he's definitely out for vengeance
which is something we kind of expected
but now we got some new information
about doc ock this one was a little bit
weird because at the end of spider-man 2
he turned good he discovered that peter
parker was actually spider-man he took
control over his arms instead of them
controlling him and he ended up saving
the day so what happened why is he all
of a sudden back to being evil well
alfred molina says in the spot doc ock
picks up where he left off and we even
see him say what have you done with my
machine and in this part we hear alfred
molina say he's looking for revenge then
he says in the tv spot you want to play
games and this is where the bridge fight
starts now let me explain to you exactly
what is happening in the scene this very
clearly all takes place before alfred
molina realizes that this spider-man is
not toby maguire spider-man you're not
peter pogba i am so confused right now
so here are the order of events for this
scene right here the infamous bridge
scene a lot of chaos starts happening
the villains show up at least doc ock
we've seen some footage that lead us to
believe that the green goblin may be in
the scene as well but at least doc ock
and this causes peter to put on his nano
tech suit now it's already on him just
like tony stark had his iron man suit on
him so it kind of just goes around him
and appears this is before doc ock can
see him so peter does this before the
actual fight then doc ock shows up and
all he sees is the spider-man suit he
acknowledges that it is a new suit
however in one of the tv spots he says
you think your fancy new suit's going to
help you but i believe that's actually
after he asks peter parker thinking that
it's toby's peter parker from his world
what have you done with my machine and
obviously tom holland's peter has no
idea what he's talking about and he
doesn't know who doc is so he's going to
say i have no idea what you're talking
about i don't know what machine you're
referring to and this is where doc ock
will say you want to play games and
they'll start to fight now eventually it
looks like doc gets the upper hand we
have the footage where it looks like doc
got kind of takes the nanotech from
peter parker's iron spider suit whether
that's peter trying to do something new
with his suit and it goes wrong or doc
ock figures out a way to take it from
him so doc ock gets the best of peter
parker here he gets unmasked and he
realizes that this isn't toby maguire
and that's where we get that infamous
line you're not peter and this is
probably where the villains will really
start to realize what is happening
realizing that they're not actually in
the same universe as they were before
and doctor strange will most likely show
up here because we do know that at least
doc ock is going to be captured and put
in a prison inside of the sanctum now
we've seen supposed leaked photos of all
of the villains in prison but that's not
confirmed to be real yet but i have
heard a plot leak that has been proven
to be real that says that they all get
put in prison but then they escape but
right now all the tv spots have
confirmed is that at least doc ock gets
captured but one thing is for sure the
villains obviously realize that they
have a new world here and this is where
we get the new green goblin footage
where willem dafoe actually fills us in
a little bit on his character's motives
and he says that the green goblin
believes that in a world of losers and
winners power is all that matters and
this is where we get the new footage of
him on his glider without his mask on
some people are calling this the
homeless look for the green goblin
because he's wearing a suit but he is
wearing raggedy clothes on top of it now
really what this is is their shot at
making the green goblin a comic accurate
green goblin with the purple clothes on
the hood and i'm actually really digging
it and we very briefly see him turn
around on his glider and see that indeed
he is not wearing a mask he doesn't have
the green goblin helmet on anymore
however he does have a pumpkin bomb in
his hand he arms it and he throws it at
somebody doesn't throw it at spider-man
because we can see tom holland jump and
try to save whoever he throws it at and
it looks like tom holland gets pretty
messed up in the scene as it explodes
pretty close to his face now lately
there has been a lot of talk
about aunt may dying or happy hogan
dying but marisa tomei who plays aunt
may said that she actually had to see a
therapist in real life due to the ending
of spiderman no way home so that means
the ending is going to be very very
intense and i'm assuming that a death is
going to be involved in some way now
marvel isn't really afraid to kill
people there have been some deaths in
the past two marvel movies no spoilers
on who they were but if you've seen them
you know however this is very different
we've seen happy since the very first
mcu film iron man and marisa tomei's
aunt may has been with us since captain
america civil war these characters have
been around for a long time we're
invested in these characters we care for
these characters it's not like they're
just introducing them and then killing
them now of course there is no guarantee
that anybody is going to die but judging
by what people are saying and how sad
they're saying it's going to be i think
we're in for a pretty big whirlwind in
spider-man no way home i think the
ending is truly going to shape the rest
of the mcu i really think this is going
to be a heck of a movie and i don't know
if we're ready for it but whether we're
ready for it or not it comes out in a
week and i know most of us are going to
be there on opening day if not i know
people are going to be watching it soon
after it releases so only one week to go
let me know how excited you are about it
in the comments down below and of course
let me know what you thought about this
new footage that we see don't forget to
subscribe and like the video and of
course for live updates you can always
follow me on instagram and twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you